everywhere you look in Bethlehem hotels
are shut and streets are empty from
those overlooking manger Square to
British Artist banksy's wal off hotel
which has a less appealing view but
almost all are closed for business and
taking No
Reservations until now actually we
didn't receive any kind of pilgrims
tourist or any kind of uh maybe
clergymen or I mean priests or monks or
uh sisters because you know Bethlehem is
a lock down and nobody can enter and
exit and sometimes actually it's
difficult for them to come in a place
where it's sometimes it's terrified or
scared about it Israel closed major
roads into Bethlehem when it declared
war on Hamas and launched a military
offensive in Gaza and that war has led
to thousands of pilgrims and tourists
cancelling their trips said this the our
Christmas where Jesus born hotels are
empty nothing here no body come H it's
closed
streets uh they didn't allow anyone from
the Israeli side or abroad to come to
visit Bethlehem as a Palestinian
Christian Palestinian I cannot go to
Jerusalem either to pray or to do my my
business or facilities elas says there
are around 5,200 hotel rooms in
Bethlehem and the industry employs 3,000
people and another 3,000 subcontractors
now he says fewer than 500 are working
at this time of year hotel rooms across
Bethlehem are usually at full occupancy
with guest booking months in advance now
look empty room after empty room after
empty room this hotel would usually
accommodate 220 people now there are
only five guests staying it's the same
story across the city 70% of bethlehem's
economy relies on tourism most of it's
made during the Christmas holidays one
research monitoring Institute says
Israeli settlers are hoping to take
advantage of the
situation Bethlehem has about 23
settlement that exist uh all over the
governor Gat ham settlements that has
declared tender to build about 1100
hotel rooms within its uh its border
also har settlement now is expanding
into the tourism sector Bethlehem toned
down festivities this year there was no
traditional Christmas tree decorations
or Carol events in solidarity with
Palestinians in Gaza but people say it's
the Israeli checkpoints road closures
and fear of visiting during the war
that's forcing businesses to shut down
Laura Khan aljazera Bethlehem in the
occupied West
Bank make sure to subscribe to our
Channel to get the latest news from
aler